i think the game itself was really worth
it like i could have blundered in 20
moves you could have blundered in 20
moves
but we ended up producing like a super
instructive game
with a little bit of everything right we
have a super instructive end game
we have uh isolated puns double pawns
king.cant castle
bishop pear the whole thing i completely
agree and
guest appearance from your cat
[Music]
who is the 20 000th game going to be
again
it's going to be another streamer i'll
be playing
the one the only lafong
school lead sku okay so um i did very
very minimal
preparation i know he plays g6 here
i didn't really look beyond this but i'm
going to go for
this line and bishop b5
it's a tricky variation so i'm
discouraging knight c6 if black plays it
i'll i'll take
if a6 i'll play e5 20 000. oh thanks so
much
i appreciate that cd latremont
yeah maybe i should have looked into
this line a bit deeper
it's so complex uh
because there's pawns all over the place
knight c6 i think is the most natural
move here
i have a choice where to move the queen
play queen d3
i studied this line
years ago this is probably like the most
critical line in this variation
i'm pretty sure black is supposed to
play e6 but i'm not entirely sure
so i could just take a pawn here
i think i'll take a pawn the square
is kind of tender look at this beautiful
structure
of two very healthy pong islands
and black structures a little bit a
little bit crippled
mesopotamia oh
uh not right now let's stay focused
let's play queen e2
and thank you cd latremont gifting subs
appreciate that so queen e2 it's a
defensive move
but it's also making a threat i'm
threatening f4
[Music]
so now i'm threatening wait a minute
do i lafong the lefong this is not
really a true lafong
but bishop h6 is like the move he's
known for
and such a good move i think i could
also play f4
wait a minute let's think calculation
time
because this prevents black from
castling
if i play f4 the knight just moves i
have knight d6 but then king f8
apple watch oh apple wash wants me to
stand up and
walk but not right now
um so f4 here
i mean it looks really fancy but i think
i should
play this first and now if the knight
moves
this is mate it's so beautiful
so this is actually a massive threat
okay d5 is very logical i guess the idea
may be knight g4
hmm
i'll take this seriously congrats on
20kly chess games eric
i've really enjoyed your content on it
you have reinvigorated
my love of the game oh good to hear
appreciate that uh
but what to do i don't think f4 actually
is so effective here
i might just play h3
h3 i mean there's also a line here here
takes takes f4
i'm going for h3 it's kind of slow
looking
but i'm just trying to restrict black
i've been restricting this and this and
this
if the bishop moves f4 happens
i guess there's some idea bishop d3 now
things can get really really crazy
okay so i'm going to focus on central
play
i'm allowing this for this if knight t3
i just play king f1
then i'll be threatening to take and
take
i think i have the i have the daily game
open in another tab
uh so my opponent had played a move
okay let's focus on this so bishop e4
um f3
maybe knight off three
just developing
there's a funny line takes takes and
then the bishop's pretty much stuck
i'm really trying to someday get some
nice pressure along e file
[Music]
okay this is a threat now so probably
king g1
there's also this this is almost mate if
only the knight or queen wouldn't be
able to block
i'll play king g1 king is safer here
this is no longer a concern
i might even play like king h2 and then
get the rook
involved
hmm
lafong is challenging my lafong bishop
i could play bishop four maybe
what else to do
and bishop f4 there's bishop d6
so i could play queen e3 actually let's
start with this
um
for some reason i've i forgot black can
do this
now i can't play bishop h6 back
three oh thanks for the three
like a leaf i have this move
oh i have this move too
it's a weird position because i've like
i've basically one move to do something
before black consolidates
knight d2 is probably the way to go at
least making a threat
and then in bishop d3 i play queen e3
and i'm threatening to take and take
here i'm just writing to win a pawn
if f5 i have f3
it's a tense position
in rows and t oh thanks except
it's m rosen orange juice for now
okay so i want a pawn
i can't complain opening success kind of
maybe there is something better but okay
now i just have to watch my time
wait lefong's 1500 oh he doesn't have a
i guess he doesn't have a rapid oh
that's so funny
so this is my twenty thousand lee chess
game
and this is his first ever elite chess
rapid game
i guess he plays blitz and bullets
so now if i take there's this move
play this there's this move so queen e2
[Music]
there's some idea of like eventually
playing bishop h6 back
whoa it's kuggle booch
i don't know how to say this name but
thanks for reading i really appreciate
that
google booch shout out
is this the battle of the unofficial
chess bras
uh i guess sure why not
play this move maybe hi eric i knew
about you about a year ago but started
watching
all of your videos on youtube videos
chess youtuber now i have finally caught
a stream
welcome keep up the good
videos are like a combination of cheetos
and videos
i appreciate the kind words if you're
just joining i'm playing chess and this
is my
twenty thousandth game only chess
and i'm trying to make it a good one i'm
playing lafong hua
who um he's pretty well known in the
chess world
um he recently started his own twitch
channel
i'm up a pawn but he's up on time
the queen is nice here threatening
various things
so rook a5 looks interesting but then i
just take the pawn
and there's no rook b8
yeah shout out again to cooglebooch i
really appreciate the the raid the
support
um so i can win another pawn maybe
uh or i could flag
prefer not flagging
[Music]
i think i'll play knight f3 knight will
keep my king safe
still have the threat of this now my
bishop controls
b8 the king still wants to
i guess go here and the rooks want to
connect
yeah that's a move
and bishop e3 and there's f4 let's play
bishop
g5 hitting the queen
thanks for subbing oh kuga booch
gifted by cd latremont thanks so much
yeah queen c7 good move
probably should i should have played
bishop e3 first
so i only helped black improve there but
now maybe i have this idea
so i'm actually i'm preventing rook d8
okay brookie it's a fine move
[Music]
i don't know what to do play this
trying to align with the king
i mean the hope is to eventually get
this with some like double attack
okay so i have to live on the increments
yeah rookie and i take and i think
everything's defended
your time it's making me sweat um
i'm just going to turn off alert box for
the rest of the game
okay so i guess i'm losing back upon
it's not the end of the world
except i'm i'm kind of much worse here
unfortunately
but i could also maybe play this move
[Music]
to try this
this is going downhill kind of quickly
yeah i'm i'm playing for a draw
unfortunately
um
the thing is this should be holdable
just because
the pawn like black's pawns are doubled
so it's hard to make a pass pawn
oh um
i have a crazy idea to play a6
i don't think it works though
okay
oh i'm about to get tortured
also thank you sheep this gifting a sub
to all the way something something
wait do i have this move takes takes no
king f6 king e5
okay
yeah i'm actually not sure like if uh
like what the objective result should be
eventually black's gonna go for g5
uh
making h3 just to start
oh how to do this i don't want to take
probably check
i wanted to take
oops as a mouse slip but okay it doesn't
really make a difference which square to
move to
okay now this could be a threat
okay so i all i want to do is take and
then
um ruin black structure
he's not allowing me to do that though
okay going after this pawn now
and it's a tense position
it's the thing with increment two like i
really have to be accurate
king h4 it takes
i think this is okay
it better be okay
yeah so i'm calculating take something
king here
and eventually i'm gonna win i'm gonna
win this pawn
let's go does it matter
or maybe it does matte no no it
shouldn't matter
wait how do i not lose this
am i losing this
oh it's some weird like
wait how do i not
oh no i might be losing this
i f3 king h2 i think
now i'm losing this wow
that's insane
no
[Music]
wow maybe i was losing the whole time
i don't know yeah i resign
ah wow he played that really well is it
losing
i saw i was wow good game well played
that's unfortunate i lost my 20 000th
game
is this position really losing though
okay let me um i'm going to invite
lefong
on stream and he's going to teach me
his ways lafong how's it going
i i have to feel bad i mean you better
feel bad
i i have absolutely nothing
to win by winning this game right i'm
ruining your moments i
that was my moment and you you crushed
my hopes and dreams
i i mean of greatness 20 000th game
i'm so honored to play against you i'm
honored to be the one playing against
you
but at the end of the day i'm a chess
player right i can't
i have to try my best right i can't uh
yeah
but uh well no you you tortured me in
this end game too i i thought i was
gonna survive
and then somehow you pulled some magic
trick i don't know what happened
was ready to shake hands after our kings
were on f5 and f3
me too yeah and like i was like this is
a draw and actually i don't even know
how you draw this
is it is it even drawn i think it might
actually be losing because your king is
is so active
i can invite you to a study and we can
eric you know what's the problem
we're only friends in real life oh but
not only chess
exactly ah well but now i
allowed everyone even people like you
who are not my friends
i guess now that you beat me you can you
can safely
have me as a friend and not oh i thought
it was going to be the opposite
since i beat you it cannot be your
friend well
yeah maybe that too i don't know but
temporarily you have to be
to make this work no actually i allowed
everyone to invite me now
oh great okay that's good okay all right
so i'm in the study
awesome i have the game i can't flip the
board without accepting uh
without affecting your side right just
press f yeah yeah yeah
and then all right yeah uh well
move two you surprised me already and
the minute you played knight c3 i was
like oh god why didn't why didn't i
ever study this lane in my whole life
because because i've been doing some
prep
um you know how i was telling you that
on my own stream i played the training
rapid games with an anonymous fm
yeah so that guy plays knight f3 and
queen takes d4 all the time
so f3 yes so i'm very familiar with
those lines but
knight three i don't know the subtleties
between knight of three knight c3
it's slightly different yeah bishop b5
is like a more tricky line
you uh definitely tricked me yeah so
after
um after queen takes d4
all in so i don't know if you caught the
the part of my stream
um right before we played but i was
actually preparing for you
i was looking through your games if i if
i
knew i wouldn't have showered and
i would have uh definitely uh caught
that that prep i only
uh i was only in your stream while we
were playing gotcha
yeah so i i basically filtered through
all your online games
and and wow determined that you play
this line and i'd go for this just to be
tricky
so i guess it kind of worked but you
played the most critical variation
like this um after bishop b5 a6 this is
all probably what black should do
okay and then
uh this position is really tricky i
think you should play knight c6
oh you did play knight c6 actually uh i
think i played ef6
and right after i heard that you said
that i was supposed to be e6 or
something oh yeah e6 i think is a
better move or even before here
actually computer wants d5 for some
reason it's a really like weird position
well it's not quite easy to understand
the problem in those lines is that it's
a blitz and i
i don't necessarily count the amount of
pawns so after going ef6
and you going knight b5 i'm like okay
wait i have
a set of double pawns and two isolated
pawns
and i'm not even up material so
something has gone wrong
i i was happy about the structure i mean
the one
thing that you have is a bishop hair
which is something like it could be nice
with the
position if you complete development but
it was a problem for you actually
completing development
because you you had issues with castling
i was so happy here to play bishop h6
against you
so i don't think many players uh would
win as black
playing bishop b4 bishop e7 bishop f8
and bishop g7 in the game right
like it's not really recommended yeah no
you well
you kind of did what you had to do
though because you
you didn't get pinned along the the file
and you were able to castle eventually
it was really annoying that that bishop
h6 move is really strong
not to make any kind of jokes but like
it was really a
an annoying move to face no you were my
inspiration for it
yes and it was like objectively good too
it wasn't even a dirty trick
i feel like maybe i played too slowly i
really wanted to play f4 here
but then knight g4 over here and my
bishop got stuck
i maybe i can still go for this and and
then get my rook into a really nice
position yeah
yeah i don't know what's happening here
because usually i would manual
castle with king f8 king g8 but with the
rook on g7 it's kind of weird to attract
my own rook
right yeah i don't know what like what
to make of this but it's probably more
pleasant for me
for sure so yeah i was happy and then
oh i was proud of this like it's
actually
like kind of a like i'm just repeating
moves but i'm improving the position
because i'm uh
i'm not allowing you to castle so if you
if you go back to e1 then then i
then i don't repeat but it's kind of a
weird concept right to to go there and
come back
yeah like it's funny but this would not
um
even though it's a like same looking
position
it's it doesn't count for threefold like
we haven't repeated the same position
twice
because castling is not legal here wait
what seriously
yeah so if we were to repeat again this
is not yet a draw
even though the same like visually the
same position has occurred three times
it's not it's not the same fan
this is twice now yeah but what if i go
a third time
then it's a drop even though you can't
castle right
so a third so uh how do i explain this
so after move 16 yeah so move 16
or no move 15 yeah move
17 yeah and move 19
yeah are all the same position yeah but
you can't claim threefold
because on move 15 i had casting rights
no way eric you're teaching me a rule
that i wasn't aware of
really so so the position is not the
same
if all the legal moves are not the same
this is what i understand so it's a
different position yes wow we would have
to repeat it four times
to claim a draw basically yeah like wow
the same thing occurs if there is like
on pissant possibilities
this is i think where i first like
realized this is
like a a unique case wow
i am mind blown by this role so
yeah it's just like because you know
like the fan code
um like the this yes yes series of
characters which determines a legal
position
um it's a different fan like at the end
of the fan you you determine if there's
casting rights
wow um so it's it doesn't happen all the
time but
yeah you wouldn't be able to claim it
until yeah i guess one more
time repeating okay um
but i didn't want to draw in this case
either because
i i was playing for a win of course and
bishop f8 was i think a very strong move
here
well it's based on the fact that i have
a lot of pieces on the e file
right like normally i couldn't do that
but also
i'm very fortunate that if you take on
e5 not only you're
establishing my pawn structure but your
knight is attack on d4 so you don't have
time for f3
yeah yeah i was unfortunate
uh i'm on the verge of being okay here
right i don't know it's the eval but
yeah we both have i could check if i
have anything
i mean i'm like i should be slightly
better because of the structure but
the engine is just just just saying
equal it's saying queen b5 and then
trade stuff
but then
[Music]
okay i managed to win a pawn but it
wasn't easy
i so my my feeling here
is that i think i was up on time and
people who know me by reputation
they know that i don't always play the
best move or the most sound move but i
play a lot by intuition
and my intuition told me here that if
i'm down upon and i can keep your king
from going to h2
i'm gonna have some counter play or on
my channel they call this
dirt so that that was my strategy here
like i wasn't sure
if stacking on e4 is objectively good i
didn't really calculate
but it is it is maybe easier to play in
blitz just because it's a more open
position your rooks are connected
earlier than mine and uh
and yeah i never i guess i didn't get
the chance to play king h2
like i wanted to do it here but then
knight g4
yeah and yeah then i lose a queen
yeah um so i play queen b5 oh
just a side note uh after queen b5 i
consider rook a5 queen b7
but i couldn't make knight d3 work
because of knight c6
oh and unfortunately i
i can't play queen d5 because when you
take my queen is attacked
otherwise i could second exchange and
play knight takes f4 and threat made on
g2
but i wasn't in time for it oh yeah
unfortunately
you so that that's what i saw i almost
played rook a5 but i was i couldn't make
it work
so unfortunately um again
i played knight c6 with the same spirit
i was like well
i'm already down the pond so might as
well prevent h2
and uh yeah here i sacked to play rookie
too i don't know how sound it is but
do you have a cat you want us i hear
cats
i didn't know you have a is this a new
cat yeah i'll be right back oh okay
wow that's like either a cat or like a
small
human so eric oh wow it's a cat i want
you to meet
binoni named after my favorite opening
oh
hi benoni how's it going that's a lot of
meowing
yes uh i know uh i i saw your your post
on instagram i know you used to have a
dog and you're a dog lover yeah no just
general animal lover okay probably half
of my instagram feed is
animals so have to uh
have to meet your cat at some some point
in time
eric if you want to play in an i am norm
tournament in montreal again
or a gm norm tournament eventually you
are welcome to uh
to to i'll host you you will uh this
will be your room right here where i am
you know where i am so awesome yes
and you will meet binoni uh anyways
let's keep going
yeah i know this this is a long game so
uh
but yeah no your play your play was um
annoying and i uh i i i often get that
it's uh it's uh rarely good i i often
got annoying
dirty and in that range
of adjective yeah which is like you can
take it as a compliment
i i wanted to like just win all your
pawns but then like
i i would be suffering yeah because i
can't play oh no no actually
you didn't take that right you went back
so i tried to be safe
i think it was a better approach though
because i feel that your knight was
guarding all the key squares such as d2
and e1
and uh if i can't get the back rank i
feel it's harder for me
yeah no i still felt okay here and then
i realized my bishop's a bit misplaced
um i i don't think i can allow f4 here
like when you play queen c7 you're
threatening f4 yeah
and then i can't play king h2 because
your queen is here
so my rook is like out of the play the
whole time it's so annoying to play this
as white especially like you were down
on time
like but but you're the streamer right
it's also harder like
i i'm completely focused while you have
to like entertain your chat
i i've been in yeah no people people
were cheering and uh
got a raid and um i was trying to
to juggle thanking people and playing
the position
um and i still felt okay
and then all of a sudden you're
threatening me in two
and you're threatening to win this i
actually
i'm almost convinced that the rook in
game is a draw so i think the way you
played
was near flawless from here um
i wanted to play bishop e3 at this point
i had less than 10 seconds
oh i have to sack if you played bishop
yeah and i like
i wanted to calculate but it's probably
just like even
you have to go king f1 you're still
probably mating me
check and bishop oh you don't have
bishop d4 okay but bishop h6
uh your favorite move yes no this would
be so unpleasant
yeah and at the very least you have a
draw mm-hmm
um yeah so i i figured i'd hunker down
and then it's easier to play i think
that's okay
i mean yeah
let's get to the the end game yeah for
sure um
because i like i know like it should
probably be drawn usually three on four
even with the structure but it does
require some accuracy
i don't know what's the strategy here do
you just stay passive and
and wait or do you harass me like you
did in the game and you forced something
um yeah maybe i was too forceful
um
because i like i have to be careful
allowing g4
so okay here i took but even allowing g4
like what's the worst that can happen if
i play g4 and you go king g2
oh that's actually true i mean let's say
you just play a move like
uh c4 i like rook c4 because
when i play g4 and i take on f3 you can
take with tempo attacking the f4 pawn
so i'll say that one more time so i like
rock c4 because g4 check you go king g2
and when i play when i play gf3 you take
and f4 is attacked
i don't have time to play k5
but okay i can play rook a5 now before
playing g4 and i guess you can just set
um and then maybe g4 king g2
gf3 king f3 or k3 and then i get in with
king g4 maybe that's how i make progress
wait so g4 here king g2 g2 gf3
king f3 rook a3 king g2 king g4
but the thing is even if you win the h
pawn
um like there there's a this like
theoretical end game where
f and g f and h pawn against no pawns
it's still a draw
yeah with proper play and with f pawn
it's probably easier for me
yeah um so maybe that's a draw
yeah i was going to say another thing
you might want to come around
but then your king lacks shelter i can
now take
and start delivering checks yeah i'm
really exposed to checks here
yeah so patience probably was uh the
better approach
um
but i like i in the moment i felt good
to play rook h6 try and provoke you to
do something
oh i really thought that was a draw
seriously like you don't really
calculate the end game with king f5 and
king of three right
you just go like okay like this is a
drama yeah
okay so i i i accidentally have table
base open
oh wait and it says so it says rook
takes e5 is a draw
wait you accidentally had table base
open during the game
and you saw no no right now right now oh
you can't have
you can't have a table base open during
that okay i was like whoa whoa whoa
okay no like i had the opening uh
the opening explorer is also table based
okay
um so if you toggle down you can see
yeah as long as there's
seven or less pieces you can see the
exact result
so what is the draw i'm really curious
so so i'm going to turn it off
because i thought i had i did what i had
to do like
i have to play king g5 here
wait a second eric king g4
king king e4 king g5
and now if i go king d3 you take on f4
and you win
oh maybe that's a draw
yeah you might be you might be right
bononi knows but he's probably just
yelling or meowing at me
like so i missed this move she's a
little princess uh
whenever i talk to other people she uh
she gets mad
oh yeah that's unfortunate
you should you should start like a cat
stream where she can like
uh eric um i i don't think you have been
tuning in enough but i have a binoni
account on my stream i have two webcams
oh you have a cat cam i have a cat oh no
way
it's called the benoni yeah i was going
to say like if
noni wants attention oh she definitely
gets it just
yeah yeah so the way okay right now the
problem is that i don't have a cat cam
so she's going crazy but during my
stream she has her spot
uh just down on the floor on the carpet
and i put a cam so she knows the cam is
on her so she's fine because people are
watching
that's nice yeah that's awesome and you
should have like different you should
have like channel point redemptions to
like
give a treat or like play with a toy or
eric this is the one thing i forgot to
set up for my stream today channel
points
but it's gonna be set up for tomorrow
nice you just reminded me
very nice yeah i'll have to you know
i'll i'll be sure to tune in later
yes and check out the benoni cam but hey
maybe this is the draw
and it's completely counter intuitive
right
yeah because i give you opposition
actually
yeah it's a matter of calculation it's
ironic but the f4 pawn is more important
than the f3 pawn in this end game
you're going after that pawn and not f3
yeah i just assumed like if i can win f3
it's
it's a draw of course uh oh
okay you're saying it's still a draw is
it still a draw my first
instinct here um is to go
to e2 so i cannot
go on the side where i have more squares
but i don't it's probably logical so can
you do i have to go king
king g4 otherwise you push f3 check
right
wait kingy two i have to go king g4
because king e4 you have f3
oh that's true yeah
yeah you're you're right like king e4 f3
so i mean
i i didn't think it makes a difference
because it's it's so symmetrical
and there's still enough squares on like
on the kingside flank
to work with um
but here where's the draw i don't know
i have absolutely no idea because if you
push f3 oh my goodness
okay okay i'm sorry guys i'm really
sorry like
uh we're really uh it's
bononi like watch uh like can she
recognize
is it it's she right it's a she yes can
she recognize like what's happening on
the computer
uh definitely when i play bad moves she
meows so she
ah yeah it just never stops
never stops the the bad moves keeps on
coming um
yeah that's unfortunate but she's really
curious erica how do
uh how how do you okay so i see ezra zev
in my chat saying
kim g2 king e4
this is what happened the game king h2
wait what just moving away to random
oh king
g4 unbelievable and now i i guess i get
long
distance opposition you go king h3 right
long distance opposition yeah and if i
play f3 you play king g4
and if i play king e2 you play king g4
this is amazing this is actually winning
for white now
yeah yeah well i wouldn't go yeah then
you have to be played defensively
wow wow no this is this is really an
instructive end game and if key
two then i just play this and then yeah
we trade and i have i have to take if i
play f3 i lose man
so i played king g one in the game which
deprived me of having this possibility
yeah and then i play king d3
and i go around and i yeah and at this
point
i think it's just losing oh no i still
have king h2 here
no king is shooking it too why is table
base saying draw then
oh king g2 f3 kg3 oh my goodness
oh yeah it's still a draw so i had so
many chances
wait you still have a draw after king h2
yeah this is insane
okay so king h2 king d2 and then king h3
i just need to get to the square wow
okay
this is amazing it's so tricky yeah it's
it's not easy like in a practical game
after fighting so hard throughout the
game so then you just be precise
well i i think the good thing is
you know your stream is very educational
and uh
at first i felt bad about winning this
game but
at the end of the day i think if
everyone is learning
and your chat see you as a as a role
model well if their role model can fail
in those end games
they won't be feeling that bad about
failing themselves right
like everybody can learn from that's
true yeah hopefully
people feel better about messing up in
their own games
yes happens to everyone so honestly like
yeah i i'm not i'm not
super like happy about winning against
you in this goes no
circumstances but i think the game
itself was really worth it like
i could have blundered in 20 moves you
could have blundered in 20 moves but we
ended up
producing like a super instructive game
with a little bit of everything right we
have a super instructive end game
we have isolated pawns double pawns
king.cant castle
bishop pear the whole thing i completely
agree and get guest appearance from your
cat
at least in the post-game analysis no no
there is a lot to take away from this
game i i hope people
enjoyed it and i i'm honestly not too
upset uh definitely
definitely some lessons i'll be taking
with me and uh
i'll have to have to practice my king
pawn endings
haven't practiced these in a while but
but this one is is actually
like i i i'm a teacher i will actually
show my student for sure
like the king and 5 and king f3 yeah no
no it's a great exercise for students
like give them this position and then
see if they can survive as white because
it's something like you you should be
able to do
even as a weaker player with enough time
in a classical game i have no doubt that
i have no doubt that you would have
survived this like it's like for sure
yeah like there are a few few different
survival methods too
but yeah with increments it's still
tough
yeah for sure for sure uh you were down
on time and that really didn't help
right i had two minutes and you had like
a few seconds
no that was a really great game